the Division two sports a number of new
game mechanics growing on the familiar
trends of the division one to areas that
have seen some changes are the weapons
and builds in this video we're going to
be covering the weapons and gear pieces
and how they behave in the division to
[Music]
before I get started this information is
obviously based on pre-launch experience
within the game so it's possible that
some of what you see here could change
but in saying that I'll be covering this
from a purely fundamental point of view
and at the stage so close to launch most
of this is unlikely to be changed it's
been confirmed that there will be set
pieces but so far we haven't had a huge
amount of information on these so I'll
leave these up for another video
same as the Division one and like most
other role-playing games the higher the
rarity the more powerful the item but
for the purpose of this video I'm going
to be talking about the high end gear it
should be noted that the same principles
apply to the other rarity types just on
a lower scale to keep this simple
or break down a gear piece into the
following groups brands its attributes
talents we still have grays blues
purples golds etc but within most of
these we also have brain sets now I'm
not going to go into too much depth but
basically these are like the sets we've
been using for the last three years have
these replaced sets no they're more like
a preset set brands are a more readily
available version of a set item most
items even from early on in the game
have a brand associated with them the
more of these you have equipped up to a
total of three the more bonuses you'll
gain for example you could have three of
the wave and where brand set providing
the extra attributes of critical hit
damage drone skill power and critical
hit chance and three of the elf summit
armament brand that will give you a
cooldown reduction skill power and hive
skill power alternatively you could use
three different brain sets gaining the
two piece bonus of each given the number
of brain sets available the build
options are looking to be quite diverse
even from early on in the game but
whether they're a brand piece or not
items come with a talent and a varying
number of attributes the number of
attributes a piece has seems to come
down to R and G but there are some
things that seem to define this number
and one of these is mod slots
unlike the division one a piece can drop
with an uncertain number of mod slots it
could have one or you could get up to
three but there is a drawback to having
a higher number of slots and that it
seems to affect the number of attributes
a piece can have so more slots can
potentially equal less attributes on the
gear the talent is similar to what we
used to in the division one for example
the savage gloves except in the Division
two this talent may require unlocking as
we can see here in order to unlock the
spotter talent we need a minimum of this
battery shaped icon I'll go into more
detail on this later in the video
gear mods are back in the division too
and with this new random slot number
there'll be a hell of a lot more useful
mods come with up to three attributes so
if you look at a piece with three mod
slots some attributes and a talent we're
looking at quite a large amount of build
diversity options out there also some of
the mods seem to come with quite
specific bonuses like assault rifle
critical hit chance and LMG critical hit
damage relating more directly to weapon
archetypes rather than a general
all-round weapon buff you'll see that
there's also another slot on gear pieces
the circle thing the die slot we now
have the option to further customize
each individual piece with the skin of
some sort with looter shooters it's
pretty important these days we all want
to be able to dress and make our
characters look the way we want this is
the true in-game while we're on mods
that probably wouldn't hurt to touch
based on the skills to wear some of our
gear mods would affect the efficiency of
our skills in the division 1 the
division 2 is gone in a different
direction allowing us to instead equip
mods directly to the skill each of the
skills can have three different types of
mods equipped to them for example the
drone has a battery slot a hull slot and
a feed slot and their mods each require
a certain amount of skill power to
activate them based on the number of
skills we have at our disposal this
means a lot of farming for the right
mods some of these slots could even be
compared to the way that different skill
mod options work in the division 1 and
yes again you'll have noticed the circle
but instead of being a die slot skills
have an FX slot we didn't see any
examples of these but they could be ways
to change the effect that your skills
have while using them maybe it's just
changing the color of the healer drone
or the explosion of the seeker mind well
maybe it's like that skull and halo
where the grunts would explode into a
shower of confetti when you landed a
headshot on them
[Applause]
like the gear we have the same rarity
options but again I'm going to focus on
the high-end witness because let's face
it until you get to the stage of
equipping goals and maybe Purple's
better weapons we'll be dropping as you
level up anyway I've broken the weapons
down into two groups stats and talents
starting from the top we have the weapon
archetype and bonus below that we have
the damage rpm and make size this is the
same as a Division one after that we
have some new additions this information
has always been available however has
never been displayed like we have here
at a quick glance we can see these extra
stats on the weapons including the
accuracy and stability bars you reload
time critical strike wrench and even a
damage drop-off chart this might not
mean a lot on their own but the damn
useful when you start comparing weapons
high-end weapons still have three
talents but rather than having talents
that could appear in any slot we have
three different types of weapon talents
talent 1 we could call this one the main
talent as it seems to add quite a unique
bonus that could change the way that you
use the weapon for example on this UMP
in order to gain spike and increase in
skill damage you'll need to land
headshot kills talent too I'm calling
this one the passive talent this bonus
is one that could often be seen in the
division 1 weapon mods these are a bit
more straightforward and don't seem to
require unlocking although they don't
look like the most exciting bonuses they
could lead to different decisions when
looking at the weapon mods talent 3 this
is the Holston slash unholstered talent
this slot offers one of two different
types of bonuses one where you'd have
the weapon physically in your hands or
another where you simply have to have
the weapon on your build essentially
offering a passive bonus this could open
up at a large number of possibilities
for example if you have the main weapon
and two weapons that offer hosted
talents you could have up to five
talents activated on the one weapon like
the division 1 some of these talents
have requirements in order to be
unlocked
but these aren't based off your main
stats anymore now they're based of you
gear all talents that your gear and gear
mods have are based on one of the three
different groups damage defensive and
utility and these are shown by these
icons the requirements of most of the
weapon talents need you to have a
minimum of one type for instance this
one preservation
requires you to have at least five
defense points but also some depend on
you having less than a certain amount
like steady handed in order to unlock
this talent you need to have five or
less damage points of course not
everything has a prerequisite and some
might be as simple as just equipping the
right scope weapon mods I won't talk
about these for too long as I think a
lot of you are already aware of what's
happening in the space but summing up we
no longer clicked and hold on to
hundreds of weapon mods only to use them
on the specific build that you never got
around to making especially when we
always just ended up using the same bist
and slot mods anyway now weapon mods are
unlocked and can be used on any weapon
they fit on no more collecting also you
don't get a straight bonus to whip in
any more each mod gives a positive and
negative effect so if you were to choose
the sturdy extended make for your weapon
this would give you 30 extra rounds but
also remove the percentage of reload
speed from the weapon I know a lot of
people weren't all they're happy with
this saying it was a step backwards and
built diversity but I think it's quite
the opposite from what we can see every
weapon mod now has a use and because of
this positive negative effect you need
to put in some consideration before
throwing on a mod to fill the slot you
need to have a plan for what you're
trying to achieve with your build rather
than just checking on the usual critical
hit chance muzzle and the extended back
with all of the changes coming around to
the division - it may look like a scary
place to start but to be honest once you
get your head around the new user
interface not too much is different the
same concepts are there with just a few
changes to the mods and the way the
talents work it's hard to say at the
stage before the full game has been
released but given the sheer number of
talents available on the mods weapons
and gear there's gonna be a lot to farm
for I'm an old-school RPG ER and I love
the grind provided there's actually
something to grind for of course and so
far it's looking pretty damn good what
this comes the extended build diversity
fingers crossed that we won't see any
more classified gear making a comeback
anyway I hope this has helped ease some
of the confusion around the way the gear
and weapons work in the division -
otherwise let me know in the comments if
you have any further questions Cheers
you
you